welcome to deconstructing chatbots I am
Priyanka Vergara and in this episode we
will learn how to create an app engine
front-end for our dialogue flow agents
[Music]
so far in this series we've been
focusing on learning the basics of
conversational AI and building an agent
once the agent is built you may want to
integrate it with the front-end of your
choice to give it a look and feel of
your own website well today we will
learn to create a custom front-end for a
dialogue flow chat application on App
Engine using the Django framework you
can use any front-end framework or
language you like django is just an
example we are working with here but
before we begin here's what we are
building there'll be a text input and a
submit button to send chat messages all
the messages back and forth will be
visible on the chat window alright so
let's see how this will work the chat
app will be served on App Engine we will
build our app in Python using Django
which is a python-based free and open
source web framework App Engine will
interact with cloud sequel for any
database requests and it will interact
with our dialogue flow agent
we are the dialogue flow API in this
example we'll be using the appointment
scheduler agent that we created in the
third episode and we enhanced it in the
eighth episode to integrate with Google
Calendar now with that background let's
dive in and see how to make this work
check out the link in the description
below to download the source code for
django app we will be deploying on App
Engine let's start by creating the cloud
sequel instance in GCP console once
created take note of the connection name
also create the database with username
and password if you don't already have
the cloud sequel proxy then download and
install it you'll find the link in the
description below
start the cloud sequel proxy with the
connection name we copied while
creating the cloud sequel instance this
establishes a connection from your local
computer to your cloud sequel instance
for local testing purposes keep the
cloud sequel proxy running the entire
time you test your app locally while we
are in GCP console let's download the
service account key as well from the
hamburger menu navigate to the API and
services click on create credentials
button drop down then select the service
account key name the key and make sure
JSON is selected then click create the
JSON file will then download on your
computer open settings start py in my
site folder in two places replace your
username and your password with the
database username and password you just
created this helps set up the connection
to the database for both App Engine
deployments and local testing also
replace cloud sequel your connection
name corresponding to the host replace
your database with the name of the cloud
sequel database you created when done
close and save settings start py now
let's set up the dialog flow detect
intent endpoint to be called from the
application for that navigate to view
start py file in the chat folder and
change the Google project ID to your GCP
project ID appointment scheduler dot
JSON file is used to authenticate and
authorize the app to make calls to the
dialog flow API you replace that file
with your own JSON credentials that we
generated earlier to run the django app
on your local computer we will need to
setup a Python development environment
CD into the project directory run the
command virtual Ian we env - P Python 3
to create the virtual environment now
execute source env /bin slash activate
to activate the virtual and
we just created you will see env in the
terminal which indicates that you are in
the virtual environment now execute pip
install - our requirements txt this will
install the requirements for Jengo
dialogue flow and pi my sequel then run
the three migration commands to setup
the models Python 3 managed or py make
migrations make migration poles and
migrate at this point we are ready to
start the local web server for that
execute Python 3 managed our py run
server once the server is running
navigate to localhost colon 8080 now we
are ready to deploy our app to app
engine for that we need to gather all
our static files in one folder using the
command Python 3 manage dot py collect
static then run g-cloud app deploy to
deploy the application on App Engine
this may take a few minutes but once
done you will see the link to the
deployed application in your terminal
navigate to the app and verify that
everything is working fine today we
learn how to create and deploy a dialog
flow front-end on App Engine using the
Django framework I'm excited to hear
which front ends you are integrating
dialog flow with tell us all about your
use case in the comments below I hope to
see you in the next episode of
deconstructing chat pods if you liked
this video and would like to see more
such content don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our Channel
[Music]